bonjour philippe pascot merci de
répondre à nos questions sur arte france
gérald darmanin reçoit donc les
représentants de journalistes à partir
de 17 heures 30 une conférence de presse
et est attendu aux alentours de 19
heures qu'est ce qu'on peut attendre de
se rendre de ce rendez-vous un
rétropédalage allègement statut quoi
qu'est ce que vous voulez attendre la
loi de toute manière va être votée été
votée donc c'est ce que j'appelle des
excuses de déculpabilisation mais il n'y
a rien à attendre
monsieur d'art marins et soldats marins
et son gouvernement ont excusez-moi
dépression fait caca dans leur culotte
et cèdent aux sirènes d'un site d'un
syndicat minoritaire de policier c'est
tout alors du coup sûr l'envoi
c'est une réunion pour rien mais non
comme d'habitude
comme la plupart des lois qui sont passe
aujourd'hui on fait semblant d'écouter
on écoute pas on fait quand même et puis
après on dit qu'on a écouté ce que le
gouvernement publiait dans mediapart
pour rappeler justement emmanuel macron
à revenir sur cette toile notamment sur
sur cet article 24
et vous croyez qu'ils vont écouter le
mediapart qui vont écouter les gens
consignés mais vous rigolez
vous avez un président de la république
qui va faire le kéké à l'étranger dans
des chaînes de télé comme al jazeera
pour prêcher pour la liberté et qui est
en train de la supprimer en france et en
plus je rappelle que cette loi est
complètement illégal et j'espère que le
conseil constitutionnel va à peut avoir
les couilles de remettre de l'ordre
là-dedans parce que rappelez vous quand
même
le précédent ministre sinistre de
l'intérieur monsieur castaner avait bien
promulguer une loi pour que chaque
policier et une caméra sur lui pendant
les manifestations
donc aujourd'hui les policiers ont le
droit de filmer les drones ont le droit
de filmer et pas nous on n'a pas le
droit de filmer les policiers mais c'est
quoi cette loi ça supprime complètement
la liberté individuelle
pourquoi journaliste devrait être
demandé l'autorisation à la préfecture
mais dans quel pays commence-t-on à
vivre vous parlez d'une du conseil
constitutionnel c'est le dernier recours
envisageables
ben j'espère tient après après il
restera la rue mais macro est en train
de nous précipiter de plus en plus dans
la rue comment voulez vous que le peuple
ne
nerveux pas aujourd'hui on est prêt sur
et de partout et en plus on n'a même
plus le droit de le dire
aujourd'hui il ya des bavures dans la
police et c'est pas une honte de le
reconnaître et on donne un quitus
juridique on donne une une façon de
faire gratuites à des gens qui
deviennent sadique au sein de la police
la commission européenne je cite se
réserve le droit d'examiner la
législation finale afin de vérifier sa
conformité avec le droit de l'union
européenne en quoi bruxelles peut t'il
infléchir la politique du gouvernement
français
excusez moi ça encore une fois c'est du
blabla la commission européenne a dit
mais comme d'habitude ne fera rien donc
elle se déculpabilise elle aussi et elle
va nous laisser gentiment nous diriger
vers un pays complètement autoritaire
c'est quoi aujourd'hui monsieur le
ministre demande à ce que les
journalistes souhait et glauque quitus
de la préfecture il y aura des bons
journalistes et des mauvais journalistes
mais c'est quoi ce pays des droits de
l'homme c'est quoi ce pays dont le kéké
je parlais tout à l'heure et en train de
vanter la liberté et la défense de la
liberté à l'étranger mais pas dans son
pays
je dis simplement que c'est une honte
vous parler de dérive autoritaire nous
allons tranquillement vers un état
autoritaire sur la tse montils de la
députée lrm nathalie sarlin elle a
répondu tout à l'heure à nos confrères
de france bleu début de fronde au sein
de la majorité au palais bourbon le
rappelle il ya déjà une scission à
l'assemblée nationale du parking
présidentielle avec la création du
groupe écologique démocratie et c'est
mérité même si second pas disparu en
octobre faute d'un effectif suffisant
mais j'espère bien qu'il ya quand même
quelques députés qui vont se réveiller
qui vont se rendre compte qu'ils sont
manipulés qu'ils sont dans un dans un
espèce de deux gouvernements qui prêche
des chose et fait le contraire
je rappelle que depuis le début du
mandat de monsieur macron on n'a pas
arrêté de couper dans les libertés
les fumélois sont les faits que news la
loi sur la sécurité
il ya plein de lois qui sont passés pour
mieux verrouiller les gens c'est une
honte
merci j'espère que le peuple va se
réveiller
merci finit pas